and the pitcher will be right-hander
casey mize making his 18th start of the
season
he's had a little bit of time off here
because of the all-star break
we'll see how his command is early in
the game the first couple innings
let's see if he attacks the strike zone
gets ahead the one-two
on the backhand paradise behind the bag
make it third
cabrera couldn't dig it out of the dirt
no now they call him out he never hit
garcia never touched first base
it was a throw that bounced miguel kind
of went down fell to the ground
as adulus garcia was crossing first base
and they're going to face the
right-hander kyle gibson he's making his
18th start
probably having the best first half of
his career
with the rangers the tigers pinned the
only l on him that he has
chopper left side of the infield and a
high hop
for connor falefa takes care of scope
two away
the 2-2 bass basketball strike three off
the plate inside
grossman took it for a reason but cb
buckner rings him up
gibson records a one two three first we
go to the second tigers hit the four-man
outfield against joey gallo oh he went
too far didn't he yes
he did and he strikes out ghetto to
start the second
late moving and boy that ball absolutely
went straight down
upright stance from the left side 3-2
ground ball left side
backhanded by paredes lauren throw to
first he got him what a fine play by
isak paredes
alone infielder on the left side shaded
up the middle had to go far to his right
and jim he let that ball go and it
jumped out of his hands
i'll tell you what he looked like a
shortstop that time didn't he i mean the
way he got the ball
upright stance needs slight reflex tucks
that left shoulder as he [ __ ] the bat
over the right he swings and pops it up
shallow center field but do over toward
right center a few steps makes the easy
grab
and that's another good inning for casey
mize the stuff is
impressive so far tonight very good six
up six
down a pretty big ballpark 420 feet to
straight away
center here at comerica park 3-2 pitches
hit right back
up the middle and knocked down by gibson
didn't field it cleanly but he
reaches down off the hill toward first
picks it up and gets it over to first in
time to retire candelario
this is his 25th appearance and his 24th
start
against detroit has a 10 and 10 career
record with an era of five and a half
here's a bouncer a high hopper down to
third holt is up with it
and the throw across is just in time to
retire haas that was a bang bang play at
first
but gibson sets them down in order we've
had 12 batters and 12 ounces
right-handed batter with an upright
stance the 2-2
swinging a soft ground ball back to mize
grabs it flips to miguel cabrera
another slider gets an easy ground ball
out two up
and two down eight up eight down
swinging a high
pop up shallow center field but dude
drifts to his left and makes the easy
catch that's
40 pitches three innings for casey mize
we'll see if he gets the handshake or he
gets another inning when he goes
into that tigers dugout i think you get
another inning i would think so
it's just a quick little step back maybe
six inches list the leg drives to home
plate soft little bloop in the center
that's going to drop for a big hit for
esa
that's what you're going to have to do
against kyle gibson just put it in play
that's the key put it in play if you
have an opportunity because
this stuff tonight is strong the 1-1 is
chopped to the right side that one's
going to get through into right field
squirting just past the second baseman
white for a basic gallows throw to third
on the money the tag in time
what a strike from joey gallow as he
nabs paredes
tigers do have a runner in scoring
position with two outs four but dude no
score
badou turns on one deep right field
gallow is back
he leaps it again two run bomb
for aquila and the tigers
are up two nothing nine up and nine down
through three innings for mize
up the middle and that one's going to
shoot through in the center field so the
rangers have their first base runner of
the ball game
it's a brockholt leadoff single here in
the top of the fourth the o2
swinging a miss fastball wow just right
mind tardy is right absolutely
tardy over-matched 2-1 so we're going to
high
pop up left side of the diamond it's
castro the shortstop moving over just
barely on to the outfield grass he makes
the call on the catch
and that ends the inning so casey mize
works around a lead off single
and the tigers have something cooking
with two outs here in the bottom of the
fourth inning
they lead two to nothing and harold
castro coming up
the 0-1 and the righties pitch is fisted
in the air just beyond the reach of wide
into right field to base it
rounding third here's candelario gallows
throwing the money the tag
in time another outfield assist as
gallows
shoots down candelario who try to slide
underneath the tag of jonah heim
but heim was there to complete the deal
and that ends
the bottom of the fourth second outfield
assist for joey in his many innings
takes a lot of discipline by aj hinch to
pull casey mize
after four innings of one hit scoreless
ball but that's what he's had to do
54 pitches works from the stretch third
base side the 3-2 pitch
swinging a miss running fast ball up and
away got him well i tell you what that
that is terrific
[ __ ] the one two swinging to miss he
got him in with a change up at 91.
that's the arm speed dan right there
that arm speed where he comes across the
ball like that
and absolutely disappeared here's the
2-2 hey strikes out the side
rangers stranded man in scoring position
nice inning
now runners it first and third with one
man out and the defense can play
at double play depth as jonathan scope
comes to the plate
ground ball base hit right side
coretta's in
nikhil badou will stop at second as
gallow closed quickly
sharp single for jonathan scope he
delivers again
three-nothing tigers in the fifth base
is juiced for miguel cabrera
would love a base hit the one-two in the
left-field corner
he delivers manu is home scope is home
grossman's motor at home he's down and
in there cabrera tries for three
out at third base
and he had one heck of a slide aj is
going to take a look there's a great
slide folks
he's safe that's a great take good job
by the coaching staff to notice that
of course we're not wearing umpire blue
uniforms he's safe well put that in the
books
he has just tied the great rogers
hornsby
and jake beckley for 38th all time and
career hits
bases are loaded with tigers again
another one too
reaches out that finds some room up the
middle one run is home
here comes zach short that is a two run
single for akil
on a 1-2 pitch off a lefty and it's
eight nothing tigers
the one-two up the middle jonathan scope
comes through again
another run trots home making
nine-nothing tigers
bases are loaded again for miguel
cabrera
the o2 through the hole on the left side
[Music]
badou scores another run coming home
and in safely is jonathan scope miguel
cabrero with two more runs batted in
another 3-2 and another walk
come on home robbie grossman and make it
12.
the o2 swinging a slicing drive down the
left-field line
martin over makes the catch tagging
miguel cabrera coming home and he will
score without a throw
now over to third goes candelario thrown
out in time
sloppy play by the rangers sacrifice fly
for castro
13 nothing tigers in the sixth buck
farmer
will try and do what jimenez and norris
did before him
come out of the bullpen and mow down the
rangers
the 3-2 he just froze him with a 94 mile
an hour
fastball at the knees well late the late
movement on that pitch outstanding
and white strikes out swinging good
change up right there
buck picks up his second strikeout
farmer strikes
out the side ranger strand two
another solid inning from another tigers
reliever
tigers have the bases loaded for the
third
consecutive inning inside ball four and
actually gets by jonah heim
another bases loaded walk a 14 nothing
lead for the tigers
yeah he's in for his second inning ian
kroll is
fly ball center field badou chases it
down with a knight
offensively defensively and pitching
wise
season best night for the tigers runs
and hits
and they boast their fifth shutout of
the season